[Musik]
du musst
man muss maximal
und damit herzlich willkommen aus meiner
hexenküche heute machen wir cocktails
wie ihr zu eurem nächsten harry potter
film abend machen könnt mit ein bisschen
und neben meiner zauberkräfte brauche
ich für diese magie natürlich sowie
die gewiss arbeitet schon seit einem
jahr mit adobe zusammen ich habe es doch
motion videos auf tik tok und instagram
hochgeladen die wirklich sehr viel
arbeit waren aber auch sehr viel spaß
gemacht haben wir haben viel dazugelernt
heute geht es um black friday wir sind
mitten in der black friday mit bei adobe
da bekommen studierende lehrkräfte
azubis zu ihrem normalen rabatt auch
nochmals 20 prozent rabatt auf die
creative cloud und alle anderen bekommen
40 rabatt das ist doch mal was schon
denn die infobox wenn ihr dazu mehr
wissen wollte und jetzt gehts los mit
dem video die rezepte die wir heute
machen sind nicht aus meinem schönen
köpfchen entstanden sondern aus dem
inoffiziellen harry potter cocktail buch
akio cockpit
[Musik]
das erste rezept was wir heute machen
werden habe ich auf meinem kanal schon
mal gemacht es ist ein butterbier
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier ist ein butterbier cocktail er ist
ein bisschen anders als die variante die
ich schon kenne und die freunde von mir
schon gemacht haben um die ich auf
meinem kanal schon gemacht habe in
diesem rezept brauchen wir butter scoach
sirup rum meist vier und schlagsahne wir
beginnen mit dem butter scotty sirup und
dafür brauchen wir 200 gramm zucker 2
120 milliliter wasser 30 gramm butter
eine prise backpulver und eine prise
zuerst brauchen wir einen top da kommt
jetzt unser zockereien die hälfte des
wassers die bruder eine prise salz dann
wenden wir natürlich in klassischen
hitze zauber an akufo-addo stufe neun
halbe stufe unter ständigem rühren
müssen die zutaten jetzt schmelzen und
danach werden sie als aufgeholt so die
masse ist jetzt geschmolzen die perfekte
butter zucker mischung und dass das
jetzt aufgekocht werden ich liebe heißen
zucker wie die
lieder wie du warst schon mal wasser
aufkochen denn wenn die masse goldbraun
ist nachdem sie auf gekocht ist dann
muss man das gekochte wasser und
backpulver dazu geben wir liebe in
heißen zuckermasse koch und vorsichtig
sein am besten auch schutzhandschuhe
anziehen weil zucker ist heiß und heißer
zucker ist gefährlich guck mal da denkt
man die ganze da passiert nichts und
dann kommt es von ganz automatisch und
wie beim daytona spiele von game machen
wir da jetzt eine prise backpulver rhein
ruhr und in unsere gefährlich jetzt
sogar masse kommt jetzt 110 milliliter
gekochtes wasser
[Musik]
genau so was hab ich erwarte täglich was
hier passiert ich habe hier so eine
kleine flasche vorbereitet um den erst
mal abzufüllen
unseren gefährlich heißen butter swatch
group lassen jetzt einmal abkühlen und
dann machen wir gleich weiter unser
bruder scott sirup ist jetzt abgekühlt
und wir brauchen zusätzlich noch
unschlagbar und 24 und jetzt müssen wir
mal schauen beim abkühlen hat sich das
nämlich so abgesetzt ich glaube
schlechter einmal so ein bisschen rum
wie flüssiges karamell 45 milliliter
brauchen wir von unserem selbstgemachten
bruders sirup
das führe ich einmal den sirup und
nochmal 45 milliliter rum war jetzt
kriegt es eine richtig gute farbe der
irrt nicht geschüttelt und jetzt fehlt
nur noch unser malzbier und das füllen
wir jetzt damit auf
also das ist jetzt bisher das beste
butterbier was ich jemals gemacht habe
sind wir noch ein bisschen schlagring
[Musik]
das ist das schönste butterbier was ich
jemals gemacht habe jetzt stellen uns
die frage wie ich meine super geile
butterbier das ist unser erster und der
ist schon so gut geworden
das ist das beste butterbier was ich bis
jetzt getrunken habe wow ich habe schon
wirklich viele bürger bier probiert aber
das hier ist das beste das schmeckt
genauso wie man sich es vorstellt
[Musik]
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten als
nächstes machen wir einen feuer whisky
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er ist in der magischen welt bekannt und
fun fact er hat sehr viel promille ich
weiß leider nicht wie viele aber er ist
sehr stark und für unseren roten feuer
whisky cocktail brauchen wir wissen
rotwein zuckersirup und eine zitronen
für diesen konnte brauchen unseren
shaker und da machen wir 60 milliliter
wisst ihr ein
60 wenn ihr zitronensaft auspressen
wollt dann rollt eure zitrone über eure
arbeitsplatte so geht der sache ich weiß
nicht ob das stimmt ich hab's aber mal
gehört holt euch eine saftpresse aus
plastik 30 milliliter zuckersirup könnte
man in dieser stelle auch selber machen
aber ihr wisst ich bin kein fan von
hitze also machen wir weißen wort sogar
sirup rein 20 milliliter
und jetzt 15 sekunden gut durch schenken
die menge verteilen wir jetzt auf zwei
gläser
und jetzt mit rotwein aufgießen
[Musik]
praktisch das ist unser roter feuer
whisky sehr schnell gemacht das finde
ich schon mal gut es fühlt sich an als
ob man wirklich einen krassen cocktail
mixt und jetzt probieren wir ihnen mal
[Musik]
tschüss bis morgen noch mit dem feuer
whisky im rachen werden wir den nächsten
cocktail machen und zwar dumbledores
zitronen brause
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und allem potter fans da draußen wissen
natürlich warum es dumbledores zitronen
browser heißt weil elvis dammtor der
schulleiter sie thronen browser bonbons
so liebt und deswegen musste der
unbedingt dabei sein was wir brauchen
ist
honig zitronensaft und zitronen draußen
pulver wir brauchen wieder unseren
cocktail shaker und dafür jetzt zur
hälfte crashed ice sein mit unserer
magischen eismaschine
20 milliliter jim
zehn milliliter zu tun sagt
und für das kleine schleckermäulchen
noch ein schuss honig deckel zu und
jetzt machen wir ein bisschen glas magic
machen ein bisschen zitronensaft auf
einen teller und auf den anderen teller
kommt unser zitronen brausepulver
jetzt nehmen wir unser martiniglas
dippen den rand in das wasser und dann
in die pause
so was hab ich ja das sieht so cool aus
sonntag müssen das gefühl rein
und jetzt stellen uns natürlich wieder
da wir diese fragen sich ob man damit
auf
dauer aber ich finde dass zitronen
brausepulver am rand echt cool weil wenn
man es trinke dann kribbelt's am mund
und ist so ein special effekt hat etwas
magisches ist aber sehr sauer aber so
mag das ja ne is dumbledore habe ich mir
mit dem nächsten weiter unser nächster
kiel ist der weasley sauer erst wie die
weasley zwillinge tschüss und etwas
sonne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und dieser kopf erstmal wieder ganz
einfach zutaten zusammenmischen unfertig
und das sind die zutaten amaretto
orangensaft die kurden saft zuckersirup
und eine zitrone und jetzt müssen wir
einfach mal wieder zutaten miteinander
nicht so einfach uns hier in der
hexenküche soll ja auch nicht immer zu
kompliziert sein wir geben ein eiswürfel
in ein glas und dann kommt in unser glas
einfach alle zu laden rein amaretto 50
milliliter und
das geben wir in unseren shaker heißt
ich mir in der zitronensaft zitronensaft
zehn milliliter orangensaft auch in den
shaker und unser zuckersirup darf
natürlich nicht fehlen deckel zu und gut
entschuldigen sie bitte für diese kurze
unterbrechung da ist jetzt der finger
trauen wird gehen wir sind klar es geht
hier alles mal alle retro
er sie doch nicht aus und jetzt könnte
man sagen fertig aber das auge isst mit
deswegen machen wir noch ein bisschen
zitronenschalen deko ganz einfach mit
einer zitrone ja die ist sehr grün aber
das liegt daran dass eine bio zitrone
ist und hier ein bisschen gelb und bio
zitrone ist natürlich wichtig damit sie
mich gewachsenes gespritzt bla bla bla
und man die schale essen kannst dann
schneide ich einfach so loslegen dann
ist einfach situationen und fertig ist
der riesling hübsch aussehen tut das
schon mal aber wie schmeckt
sehr lecker oh mein gott ich finde ihn
schon vom namen her perfekt der wesley
sauer hallo aber der geschmack ist
wirklich sehr sehr lecker als amaretto
schmeckt man so echt ganz fein nur im
hintergrund mit dem zitronensaft in
orange das ist sehr sehr lecker der ist
der beste bis jetzt sagen und jetzt
kommen wir auch schon zum letzten
cocktail jetzt brauchen wir gute
gedanken denn wir machen einen patron oz
colada
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der patron scholar da wird ein bisschen
exciting denn wir müssen ananas in einem
hochleistungs mixa hier steht das so
drin pürieren deswegen wird er dann zu
so einer art flasche zu seinem haus
flasche kamen die man schon sagen und
die zutaten die wir für den patron scola
brauchen sind 50 gramm geborene ananas
20 milliliter schlagsahne ein bisschen
ananassaft 60 milliliter rum und
kokosnuss
milchsaft und dieser cocktail wird
vielleicht durch den mixer kompliziert
ist aber auch wieder super einfach alle
zutaten in
einen behälter jeder ist harry potter
ein bisschen in der karibik flavour hier
also hier 40
hier kann man das jetzt richtig schön
sehen
wo 40 milliliter kokosmilch
100 milliliter ananas ich glaube der
wird auch lecker schmecken ich löffel
noch zehn stück also noch sieht er sehr
unspektakulär aus wie in der zauberwelt
passiert in der coque der welt jetzt
auch der zauber und es wird eine ganz
tolle max sechs
leute doktor wird richtig gut
und noch ein strohhalm rein fertig da
bin ich jetzt aber gespannt wie ein
flitzebogen brust
ja da kann man nicht viel falsch machen
das ist sehr lecker das schmeckt
tropical ein bisschen nach kurzem musik
also erst sehr lecker aber ich habe ihn
mir irgendwie besser vorgestellt oder
der ist so
und das war unser letzter cocktail ich
hoffe ich habe euch ein bisschen
inspirationen gegeben für eure nächste
film nach zu hause schreibt mir auf
jeden fall wenn ihr einen nachmacht
verlinkt nicht gerne auf instagram und
dann sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
vergesst nicht leute es ist flexride bei
ado wie das heißt ihr könnt richtig
sparen beim creative cloud aber schaut
nochmal dafür die infobox und klickt den
link an das einmal einer für studenten
und studierende und azubis und ein für
alle anderen viel spaß beim sparen wir
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder eure
mal wanne
[Musik]